Camera360 is 8 years old
But the passion to create better video experiences with new technologies
Still the same as the first day
Hello everyone, I am Xu Wei.
Founder and CEO of Pingo Technology
The love for photography actually comes from my father.
He is a photographer
I have given me a lot of enlightenment and edification in photography since I was a child.
After growing up
I also hope that the beauty of photography will be felt by more people.
And use new technologies and innovations
Give people a more powerful and flexible shooting experience
The equipment in the hands of users is becoming more diverse today.
Demand is also increasingly complicated
Want to always satisfy users and even stimulate their creative desires
Inseparable from more open platforms and more advanced technologies
Hello everyone, I am the technical director of Li Tao's Fruit Technology.
We started paying attention to Kotlin long ago.
After learning that it became the official Android development language
We decided to promote Kotlin within the company immediately.
Small-scale participation in StudyJams from the beginning
Go to the company twice a week for study courses
Our engineers are extremely enthusiastic
This is also due to Kotlin's more reasonable learning curve.
And many efficient and convenient syntax features
A lot of syntactic sugar more modern grammatical features
Such as natively supported Lambda expressions
Let Kotlin significantly improve our development efficiency
New features developed with Kotlin
It took only three months to advance to the point where it can go online.
Refactoring old code with Kotlin also benefits a lot
Nearly 200 lines of Java code
After refactoring, you only need 86 rows on average.
In terms of stability, we use a project that mostly uses the Java language.
Compared to another project that uses Kotlin
The latter has a significantly lower frequency of NullPointerException
I am the co-founder and COO of Gu Rui Pin Guo Technology.
It is important to continuously polish the details of the product.
We will overwhelm the event through Android vitals
From 4.51% to 0.01%
The crash rate dropped from 0.99% to 0.27%
Monthly score increased from 4.341 to 4.471
Camera360 after launching the innovative dynamic sticker feature
Popular in the Japanese market
This strengthens our determination to enhance the user experience with new technologies.
We will continue to pay attention to Google’s new technologies such as ARCore
To create a better image experience
First use new technology
And continuous independent research and development
Make Camera360 occupy an important position in overseas markets for a long time
We believe on Google Play
We will reach more users around the world.
And use our products to bring them more colorful smiles